Whether you're a Scrooge stan or you've already
broken out your favorite holiday sweater,
Netflix is hoping to make those long, cold
winter nights more bearable with its December
offerings.
Here's all the best stuff coming to Netflix
in December 2019.
Did you feel that?
It was a shiver going down your spine… and
you'd better get used to it.
Netflix will be streaming quite a few thrillers
and chillers in December 2019.
The question is: Can you handle it?
On December 1st, you can hunker down and watch
Dead Kids.
This Filipino film involves a gang of teenagers
who attempt to kidnap an arrogant school bully.
Things get complicated… and very dark indeed.
Then, on December 9th, you should brace yourself
for the 2017 critical darling It Comes At
Night.
The film centers around two families, both
of whom are toughing it out in a post-apocalyptic
world.
Expect plenty of paranoia, doom, dread, and
death.
Happy holidays!
On December 25th, Sweetheart starts streaming
on Netflix.
The film tells the story of Jenn, a frantic
shipwreck survivor played by Kiersey Clemons.
Thanks to a nocturnal sea monster, the very
real possibility of starving to death is the
very least of her concerns.
And if you're in the mood for handsome, bookish
stalkers that like to kill people, we've got
just the ticket.
The Netflix creep-fest You is back for a second
season on December 25th.
You're going to love it.
Like, really, really love it.
“You'll realize I'm not a maybe.
I'm the one."
Netflix has loaded its December schedule with
tons of stand-up specials.
On December 3rd, Tiffany Haddish gives us
Black Mitzvah, which finds the actress and
comedian discussing her Jewish roots and her
growing success — but funny!
Then, on December 12th, British comedian Jack
Whitehall gives us Christmas with my Father
… which will find Whitehall and his dad
sharing a West End stage for a night of laughs.
That brings us to John Mulaney & The Sack
Lunch Bunch, which debuts on December 24th.
Pitched as an old-school variety show and
designed in the style of Mister Rogers' Neighborhood,
the special features celebrity guests like
Natasha Lyonne and Jake Gyllenhaal trying
to entertain children.
Anything with Mulaney deserves your undivided
attention, so you'll definitely want to get
in on the action.
On December 10th, we'll be getting Michelle
Wolf: Joke Show, a new special from the comedian
who roasted the Trump administration at the
2018 White House Correspondents' Dinner.
Expect her to touch upon any number of hot-button
issues… including "woke" culture, modern-day
feminism, and much, much more.
If that sounds too high-minded, not to worry:
All three Austin Powers films will be hitting
the streaming service on December 1st.
Consider it a Christmastime miracle.
"Well if I'm preaching to the converted, why
are you being so slavish to the three question
form is my question?
You're not even looking at me man.
Now you're just being rude."
Perhaps you'd rather explore the grittier
side of life.
Let it suffice to say, plenty of dramatic
fare is on the way.
On December 6th, you can finally see whether
or not Marriage Story is worth all the hype.
Directed by Noah Baumbach, the film stars
Scarlett Johansson and Adam Driver as a couple
whose marriage is disintegrating.
Needless to say, it's some heavy stuff.
"How are you doing?"
On December 1st, you can get embroiled in
Spike Lee's incredible biopic Malcolm X, starring
Denzel Washington.
Or perhaps you'd rather explore The Danish
Girl, a moving romantic drama starring Eddie
Redmayne?
That one begins streaming on December 16th.
Then, on December 29th, you can take a look
at the action-drama Lawless.
The film stars Shia LaBeouf and Tom Hardy
as two fast-driving bootleggers in Prohibition-era
Virginia.
Expect lots of shootouts.
Let's say it's a cold night in December and
you're craving some adventure.
Not to worry: Netflix has got you covered.
On December 13th, you can sink your teeth
into 6 Underground, directed by Michael Bay.
It stars Ryan Reynolds as the leader of a
group of six professional criminals, all of
whom have faked their own deaths.
"Best part of being dead… is the freedom."
On December 8th, the spy thriller From Paris
with Love will instantly add some intrigue
to your life.
The film stars Jonathan Rhys Meyers and an
almost-unrecognizable John Travolta as two
agents trying to thwart terrorist plots in
Paris.
And that's not all.
On December 31st, you can start streaming
four James Bond movies starring Pierce Brosnan
— including Die Another Day, GoldenEye,
Tomorrow Never Dies, and The World Is Not
Enough.
Netflix is banking on a lot of monstrous fantasy
fare at the end of the year.
On December 5th, V Wars will be coming your
way.
Based on the popular comic books, the series
stars Ian Somerhalder as a doctor trying to
save people from a virus that turns them into…
you guessed it... vampires.
And he's not the only square-jawed heartthrob
on the lookout for creepos.
The Witcher debuts on December 20th, starring
Superman's Henry Cavill as a blonde, mysterious
monster hunter named Geralt of Rivia.
The series is an adaptation of the popular
fantasy novels and short stories by Polish
author Andrzej Sapkowski.
"They say witches can't feel human emotion.
What do you believe in?"
Craving some science fiction?
You're in luck.
Lost in Space returns to the streamer on December
24th.
And now for the festive stuff: A Christmas
Prince 3: The Royal Baby is set for release
on December 5th.
As you may recall, 2017's A Christmas Prince
involved an American journalist named Amber
— played by Rose McIver — who falls for
a royal named Richard, played by Ben Lamb.
After last year's A Christmas Prince: The
Royal Wedding, Queen Amber is pregnant with
the couple's first child — and she's also
out to solve a mystery that involves a missing
peace treaty.
"Who in this palace had the means, the opportunity,
the motive…?"
"If the sacred truce is broken….
There will be a curse on the firstborn child."
And here's another festive sequel for you:
A Cinderella Story: Christmas Wish is the
fifth installment of the film franchise that
began with 2004's A Cinderella Story.
That one starred Hilary Duff and Chad Michael
Murray.
In the latest installment, an aspiring singer
named Kat — played by Laura Marano must
overcome her "wicked" stepfamily in order
to perform at a gala.
Meanwhile, she's falling head over heels for
a certain special someone.
Will love prevail in the end?
All these questions and more will be answered...
when A Cinderella Story: Christmas Wish hits
Netflix on December 1st.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.